[Music]
breakfast is ready
no sugar
[Music]
coming
porridge
this isn't happening this isn't
happening
what's going on honey are you sick is it
a fever a stomachache chills
constipation
wait is it
that
did the
did the red peony bloom no
[Music]
say what i want 24 7 365.
i know it's a lot
but i don't got time to mess around
oh about that hustle am i right
this is gonna be the best year ever
nothing's gonna get in my way
[Music]
breakfast is ready
[Music]
is everything okay
i'm a gross red monster
[Applause]
oh look at me stay back this happened
already
what did you say
our ancestors had a mystical connection
with red pandas are you kidding me this
little quirk runs in our
sick i've always wanted a tail i'm a
freak we love you mae you're our girl
whoa you're you
any strong emotion
will release the panda abby hit me
[Music]
do you know how dangerous this is you'll
get whipped up into a frenzy and panda
all over
but maybe i like this new me
mama's girls
it's gonna be me
[Music]
bye